Underneath our rendering section of the project settings,
there are two options I want to call out
as they have a direct impact on how optimization works,
but also how your project is going to look
and how your content needs to be adjusted
once you've imported it inside of Unreal Engine 5.
First thing I want to talk about is virtual textures.
Now, virtual textures come in two different flavors,
and they allow you to have basically massive textures
with a ton of detail depending on what you are doing.
Now, you do need to enable virtual texture support
by clicking on the checkmark button.
Once you do that, you will need to restart the engine,
and it will be enabled.
Now, again, the two flavors or different types
of virtual textures are runtime virtual texture support
and streaming virtual texture support.
The main difference between the two
is that runtime virtual texture support
supports things that are procedurally generated
that need to be, say, baked down
in order to be more performant.
This is going to be things like landscapes
and any procedurally generated content.
Streaming virtual textures allow you
to stream in massive textures, often accompanied
with a UDIM workflow.
Now, one last note about the difference between these two
is that our runtime virtually texturing
is going to give us performance back
at the cost of memory.
And our streaming virtual texturing method
is going to give us memory back
at the cost of performance.
So again, if we're doing something, say, real time
where we have a player, we're probably
going to want to use the runtime virtual texturing.
And if we're doing something cinematic or something
like that, we could use the streaming virtual texturing
setup.
The next thing in rendering I want to talk about
and going to be the last thing is shadows.
By default, virtual shadow maps are enabled.
And this is the recommended shadowing method
you should be using when it comes to Unreal Engine 5.
Virtual shadow maps give you a much higher resolution shadow.
And they also are meant to work
with things like world partition, neonite, and lumen.